hey guys don't worry i know things have
seemed pretty bad in the past few weeks
and months what with the record
inflation the four dollar and five
dollar per gallon gasoline averages and
the prospect of nuclear holocaust but
have no fear
rest assured vice president kamala
harris has the answer
imagine a future
the freight trucks that deliver bread
and milk to our grocery store shelves
and the buses that take children to
school and parents to work imagine all
the heavy-duty vehicles that keep our
supply lines strong and allow our
economy to grow imagine
that they produced zero emissions
well you all imagined it
that's why we're here today
because we have the ability to see what
can be
unburdened by what has been
and then to make the possible
actually happen
imagine all the people
for
today
excuse me excuse me
i was just trying to uh to put myself in
an estate in which i could understand
what kamala harris said
from what i can tell she is saying that
we're going to have a fast-moving supply
chain someday
and the way we're going to get it is by
completely getting rid of all our
transportation infrastructure and
replacing it with uh
well that part can be worked out later
maybe drum circles it's not going to be
windmills it's not going to be solar
those barely produce any energy they're
extremely inefficient it's not going to
be nuclear that is extremely efficient
and it produces a lot of energy and we
know how to do it but
we're not going to do it for some reason
that kamala harris can't quite explain
and it's certainly not going to be oil
and gas which are relatively very
efficient and abundant and we were just
producing a lot of it a few years ago
but no more in the meantime
we're going to pay record prices for gas
with dollars that are worth nothing
thanks to the policies of a president
who sounds like lenin both john and
vladimir and vice president yoko ono
on the bright side
we may still get our free crack pipes so
at least there's a chance we can
understand what in the hell it is that
they think they're doing i'm glad you
like that clip now
hold up
ring the bell
subscribe
leave a comment maybe if you liked the
clip
make sure you get the notifications for
future videos also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher wherever you
get your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]